right i
i have been choked out by a bunch of
people
including jean labelle
hell yeah you should that's an honor
i've been choked out but i've never
choked anybody else out
okay so i know gene labelle is such a
huge
person in your story and uh just
mentioning his name saying he smiles so
much is uh his killer
for people who don't know jean labella
like how do you like what
uncle gene is pretty much the most
decorated stunt man of all time he was
uh he did fights with bruce lee and john
wayne
all the way up to rush hour and he um
was in the first ever televised mma
match because his mom was
uh a promoter a boxing promoter and set
up a
boxing versus judo televised match that
he won by the way and and and before
that
he was the world champion of judo
uh i don't know if he won the worlds but
like uh my mom said that like
every tournament they used to have like
a
grand slam champion where they would
have like all of the people who won all
the divisions fight
again against each other and he would
win that all the time i don't think she
ever saw him lose
he was like the badass before you know
that my mom looked up to back when she
was competing back in the day but i
don't think
he ever even like competed in the worlds
or anything like that it wasn't like as
big of a deal
you know like it was kind of like
building up into being a big deal you
know he was more like
he never really pursued athletics that
much and
i will recount to you uh uncle gene's
advice to me because he kept trying to
convince me to stop doing mma
and do stunts and he goes you know kid
i've won every real fight i never made a
penny
but i lost every r-e-e-l
fight and i am comfortably retired
and he basically was lag don't waste
your time on sports go new stunts
yeah is it true that
uh that brad pitt's character in quentin
tarantino's movie once upon a time in
hollywood
is based on gene labelle uh i wouldn't
doubt it but
i don't know only quentin tarantino
knows the answer to that question
i think so because because they show him
like beat up
bruce lee right like on the set
uh i mean there is a very
well-known and true story of gene
choking out stevens of gold until he
[ __ ] his pants on set
but um it could be based on that or it
could just be you know
coincidence okay so so we've established
who
jean labelle is now like i i i'm just so
excited to share my experience with them
um as it's like something that
that like the the world never got to see
it like gene labelle showed up when we
he showed up
on the set and and when i say on the set
it was
the the office you know uh for jackass
the movie
our first jackass movie and they had if
i remember correctly
like the entire cast like what where
there are nine of us and i believe he
did
all nine of us we were we were in a row
and he came up one by one and
and choked us out we were unconscious
and he he
laid us down on the ground where we kind
of like twitch a little bit but then
wake up
and and you would think going through
nine people if it was nine or
six or however many that you would
picture that taking a long time
however he [ __ ] it was like he just
squeezed and and we were out like the
way i remember in
such a short time it was like
counterintuitive it was hard to even
like believe
that we were completely unconscious so
fast and he laid us down just
like like out later out later and it was
just the systematic down the line and it
was so
artful it was so [ __ ] so [ __ ]
impressive
and i remember just thinking it wasn't
even like particularly scary
like to you know it just happened so
fast and uh
ultimately it was deemed by the
the powers that be being spike jones
you know johnny knox children um that it
was too dark
you know and and perhaps too imitatable
you know if
we if we go and include something then
you know we're exposing ourselves to
litigation if
if like you know kids just go out and
copy it so it just
it never saw the light of day but
interestingly now my story gets longer
um from having that experience our
uh buddy rest in peace ryan dunn
ryan dunn came away from that jean
labelle shoot
just for some [ __ ] reason that i
could never understand
he walked away from that feeling
educated
and qualified to go and start choking
people out himself
and he did i mean
so and and like this is what happened we
were on this tour after that movie like
touring around the whole
[ __ ] world you know with stevo's
don't try this at home tour doing dumb
stunts and getting drunk
on stage every night and ryan would say
to the crowd
who wants to get on stage and get choked
unconscious i'm going to choke someone
out and everyone's like me
me and i'm sitting there ryan no you
can't
ryan you can't just you can't do this
dude
you can't pull people out of the
audience and [ __ ]
strangle them unconscious like no and i
would like i would go into a fit
i would like i would i wouldn't even be
on stage i would like leave
the [ __ ] stage and i'd be so stressed
out like no i can't [ __ ]
even do it night after night and then
one night
or one morning i should say i'm all
[ __ ] up all
coked out like for like three days in a
row
and i'm trying to make a dvd out of this
whole tour
which like is is coming up short on
footage because
it's like groundhog's day every day with
the same routine
and there's nothing to put in the i'm
think i need something really crazy and
so i'm all [ __ ] up this morning still
awake all drunk
i go ryan [ __ ] choked me out
and so so he chokes me out once and uh
and then and then we're all we don't
like to do it again and
he ended up choking me out six
times in one day i believe it was all in
one afternoon
damn like uh and it took each time
and it wasn't like jean labelle it was
like i'm like it was so scary like
it because it wasn't quick you know it
wasn't this quick
and i'm just like i can't breathe i'm
claustrophobic i'm like i
[ __ ] hate being choked out and and
as the the as it went longer longer and
longer that each time
it took me longer to wake up like it was
just more and more disturbing
and and to make it more exciting towards
the end he's dropping me
like throwing me down where i'm landing
on my head like it was
just [ __ ] up and then uh i don't think
i ever got choked out again
until uh tim kennedy did it during
uh my comedy special my first com
my first comedy and i asked him to lift
me up and drop me
and and boy did he like my head bounced
off the stage
oh that that has to be among the worst
concussions i've ever had
and then i was uh up in the mountains in
peru
where i found this one right here wendy
um
and uh and chuck liddell choked me out
so that's like that's a bunch of times
damn dude in any case that was my gene
labella story which i took way too far
well you know don't do it anymore but if
do like the reason why he'd drop you so
quick because he was doing a blood blood
choke by cutting off your blood and not
your windpipe it's like an air choke
takes a long time blood chokes real
quick
um have someone like lift your feet up
after you're out so that makes the blood
rush back to your head
don't let them drop you down on your
head dude like come on
like you only have one brain i know i'm
not i'm not doing it anymore
and uh i don't encourage anybody to do
it but
from that from what from what i
understand the actual being choked out
isn't particularly dangerous it's just
the being dropped on your head that you
want to worry about right mm-hmm
yeah right that's not good get ready
this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you gonna piss me
off